might not be venom two but it's still
Tom Hardy hey man syphilis causes a lot
of carnage and Al Capone had syphilis we
were her ste way to bring up them you're
gonna watch the trailer free Capone and
the director of Chronicle he hasn't done
anything else nope can't think of
anything else is guys done now he's got
a spotless record you know we're in good
hands
[Music]
real black mass thing going on here now
Capone it was dead Capone was like a
king in Florida he has full-blown
dementia
I have reason to believe I could all be
an elaborate Act boss about we have
information that your client may have
tucked away a very large sum of money
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
guys like you on this place $10 we made
it promise someday we was gonna make it
me
[Music]
Oh thing that really matters
sound magic spin it's about family this
is going digital I don't know but that's
my guess just because it's the only new
drop that's a penny profile so
especially with the Josh Trank
connection maybe it doesn't look like
the kind of film that absolutely has to
go big-screen as sad as I have to say
that yeah that's fair that's fair I feel
like it's somewhere like in this middle
line of something like Untouchables and
gangster squad yeah yeah there's like a
pulp enos that doesn't overtly cross
over in this trailer but it feels like
it's right there and knowing josh trank
so their work - well from my
understanding this is following it after
he's out of prison he's been diagnosed
with dementia it looks like a lot of the
weird visuals that are at play here deal
with his psychosis and so there's things
I feel very elusive a theory a little
dreamlike haunting perhaps it's gonna be
like portrait of Capone and a sense of
looking at things he's feel sort of
haunted by whether that be things he
feels guilty over or just overall
paranoia I'm glad they're not trying to
do like a whole lifespan thing but
instead watch around the time of his
like focusing more on post glory days
and then the downfall of him that sounds
intriguing and Tom Hardy I feel like can
save almost every movie he's even if
it's like not a good movie he he can
save a movie yeah and yeah he can
I think undoubtably while there's some
questionable things about the way the
makeup looked at times and never had to
look kind of weird for a lot of it I
would say that for the most part I feel
like he'll probably do an excellent just
it's freaking Tom Hardy and a heavy role
as expected he always goes for the heavy
that's my boy ah back into never taking
the fluff he's still like the most one
of the most versatile actors out there
and the production design looks great
it's a short ass trailer though
and you think about it for a guy with
this kind of legacy and for how
bombastic it feels an exploitative a
little bit jarring having to talk about
the old Josh Trank thing yeah what made
me wonder it did because you know it
seems like what the movie actually wants
to focus on is a little bit more in
depth into the person or at least into
the twilight years of a life I wonder if
maybe they'll do some kind of thing
where we don't fully know what his
mindset was like so maybe they'll tease
us was Samara for what I got from the
trailer specifically was almost as if
they want to sell it like it's a
rollicking mob movie type thing because
Capone sets you up for that anticipation
and I don't necessarily expect it to be
that movie but I feel like there maybe
trying to sell it to us like it is oh
yeah no it's it's total manipulation if
you look at the sequences of the action
and such a there's action moments that
don't feel like it's an actual action
scene and it just feels like it's kind
of in his head and also they kind of
pull from a lot of the same moments try
and make it look like it's happening all
throughout the movie yeah I mean if it's
coming out digital I guess I'll check it
out when you hear Tom Hardy playing
Capone that actually sounds enthralling
to me that sounds very very exciting Wow
this black mass makeup just looks
exactly like a baby itch I'm making
Johnny Depp oh by the way which I
thought that makeup was better than this
the whole thing with Josh Trank in
Fantastic Four I don't really feel is an
applicable criticism here because that's
like the thing that I think a lot of
people are probably doing cuz like yeah
he did one fantastic movie and they did
a horrible movie with the word fantastic
yeah there's so much like behind the
scenes stipulations that occurred with
that well that did not turn out good I
don't want to hop on the bandwagon of
whole is probably gonna be bad because
that movie was bad when I think you mean
he's a he's a talented director all
things considered he's a very talented
director and if he's able to do more of
what he really wants to do I think
you'll probably get a good film I just
keep wondering how accurate of a
portrayal this trailer is in terms of
the action
movie would be cuz this could be really
compelling and could be visually
stunning or it can be very annoying
as my concern is it could be like a
boring movie that's borderline
pretentious like trying to be other
movies I think if I had to narrow it
down that's the thing that's missing for
me here is like one aspect of me likes
that it kind of feels like a horror
movie
yeah but going it's like the horrors of
Capone's mine like I said you know
mirroring his disease with how he's
interpreting or perceiving the world
around him I think is a really cool
concept but I'm just kind of curious
about stylistically and tonally what
this movie is trying to achieve but the
main selling point they slap his name on
here Josh ring today I think the main
selling point is just Tom Hardy as
Capone yeah yeah I mean that's the only
other question mark this trailer left me
with was Tom Hardy looks like he's
totally emerged in the role I'm sure he
will do a great job with what he's given
but this trailer I don't think super
showcased him because so many of his
moments he's just sitting there making
that face and maybe grunting but he's
got maybe like one full line of dialogue
here almost weirdly left me leaving
going I wonder what that Tom Hardy
performance is good yeah they have
dialog of him but a lot of times like
overlapping all these fast visuals
there's only a couple mo maybe just one
actually I'm not sure where the cameras
actually resting on him while he's
talking yeah but most of it you're right
he's you don't get any scenes almost
cautious with yeah I feel like this will
be an interesting curiosity and hey
hopefully it seems like the one piece of
faith I have is that Tom Hardy even if
the project doesn't turn out great he
usually has like a reason that I can see
for why he chose it true so I just hope
that I don't know maybe this bodes well
for Josh Trank in the future cuz Tom
Hardy's gonna be fine yeah alright guys
well Capone you excited for this movie
there's a Fantastic Four thing just put
a dent in you purchasing or renting this
film subscribe click the notification
bill last but not least
cameron french cameron huge movie buff
big tom party fan wrote you a poem last
month didn't hear back from you still
pledged so i'm assuming we're good
I'm assuming you love that poem when you
don't get back to me I just assume the
best all the time that's the way my mind
works someone call me a narcissist the
other day I actually don't know what
that means but I do I'm the best of what
I do oh yeah so you're welcome is what
I'm trying to get out here but guys I
wanted to show my appreciation for
Cameron
by telling you guys to go to his
Instagram page Cameron's movie reviews
over there he does a lot of talk about
wrestling and wrestling has been quite
an interesting topic but it's called
Cameron's movie reviews the other thing
is he does fantastic reviews as well the
way he is decided to structure his
topics with the visuals and the text
description is actually quite
interesting it makes for a really great
Instagram page so I highly recommend you
go to Cameron's movie reviews as soon as
you can on Instagram trust me it'll be
worth your time maybe his earn it
Thank You Cameron now slide into my
d-ends
we don't need a but of you my
you